there's a reason why plankton is
obsessed with Krabby Patties and for his
sake we're going to help him discover
what the Krusty Krab secret ingredient
really is but let's just say that some
mysteries are better left unsolved watch
until the end to find out what mr. krabs
best-kept secret is all about the krabby
patty every decent burger comes with a
squirt of delicious sauce and while
these sauces are usually ketchup or
mustard base the krabby patty is
accompanied with something entirely
different so let's get the basics out of
the way
the krabby patty is topped with lettuce
cheese tomatoes barnacle shavings onions
and sea salt these ingredients are
nothing out of the ordinary
well everything but the barnacle
shavings of course however it's what
comes next that confuses us while
ketchup mustard and tartar sauce are
listed there's a secret sauce that isn't
spongebob might be in charge of putting
the Krabby Patties together but he
hasn't the slightest clue what the
secret ingredients might be so we're
taking it upon ourselves to iron out the
details when it comes to this Krusty
Krab delicacy there are two mysteries
that arise the first one being the patty
itself and the second one being the
secret sauce it will bring the whole
world together these two secret
ingredients combine to make the best
burger ever which is why the Krusty Krab
is always jam-packed with customers if
there's one thing mr. Krabs loves more
than anything its money so we're certain
that whatever his secret ingredients are
it won't be too expensive now that you
know what a basic krabby patty looks
like let's jump right into some of the
most disturbing theories surrounding the
underwater burger imitation crabmeat
that mean it's expensive and by now we
all know that mr. Krabs is the cheapest
sea critter in bikini bottom
so by default paying for real crab meat
is out of the question the best burger
in town might very well be named after
the crab who invented it so just because
it's named after a crustacean doesn't
mean that it's made out of a crab and
besides serving real crab meat is a
little barbaric especially since mr.
Krabs has been seen chomping down on
Krabby Patties before a popular theory
floating around the internet is that mr.
crabs used his imitation crab meat to me
his patties however he'll be the last
person to confirm or deny this
so what's fake crabmeat made out of well
it's quite simple really
imitation crab is made with a fish
called surimi this fish is colorless
which is why cooks usually add spices
and colorants to it before serving it
it's a cost-effective and tasty way to
get your customers coming back for more
but in the end it's made out of 100%
surimi since mr. crabs customers are
predominantly fish this theory is more
than a little unsettling after all this
basically means that bikini bottom is a
town of cannibals but then again it's
only normal for the big fish to eat the
little fish crabmeat some spongebob fans
believe that the Krusty Krab is actually
a restaurant that supports cannibalism
and here's why first of all mr. crab
seems to be the only crab in town which
is pretty strange if you ask us so could
it be that crabs know to avoid bikini
bottom at all costs mr. Krabs is in love
with making money which is why we
wouldn't put it past him to go against
his own kind to become the richest
crustacean in the ocean just when you
thought that things couldn't get any
worse we're about to take mr. Krabs
insanity to a whole new level
mr. Krabs doesn't have a wife or a
girlfriend however he has a daughter who
looks nothing like him if crabmeat is
indeed the Krabby Patty secret
ingredient then this means that mr.
Krabs is getting his meat from somewhere
else red crabs can lay up to ten
thousand eggs in one sitting which would
be more than enough to sustain the
Krusty Krabs demand so could it be that
mr. Krabs uses his own children as fuel
for his restaurant business if this is
true it could explain why no crab has
ever fallen in love with the Krusty Krab
owner and it could also shine a light on
why Mr Krabs's daughter pearl is the
furthest thing away from a crab after
all the richest man in bikini bottom was
bound to get lonely too and he couldn't
risk having a child that he'd be tempted
to cook on the grill Texas beef Sandy
Cheeks is one of SpongeBob's best
friends but she isn't exactly an open
book sandy might be a squirrel but
that's never stopped her from living
underwater with the rest of her
friends so what's a squirrel doing in
bikini bottom
well we have some theories up here on
dry land we like to eat burgers that are
made of 100% beef so why would things be
any different for our favorite ocean
dwellers here's a theory that just might
blow your mind Krabby Patties are made
from beef and sandy is responsible for
delivering the meat to Mr Krabs's front
door sandy comes from Texas which is a
state that is known for being populated
with cattle farms so could it be that
sandy sells beef to mr. krabs in
exchange for a paycheck
to make ends meet sandy used to work for
the treedome enterprises
however this company is only mentioned
once and doesn't seem to be illegitimate
although Sandy's bosses allow her to
remain in bikini village this world
doesn't exactly have a paying job so
we're led to believe that she and mr.
Krabs are in cahoots with each other
there's no secret ingredient mr. Krabs
might be a shellfish but he's not stupid
so we wouldn't put it past him to trick
people into thinking that his restaurant
serves the best burgers in bikini bottom
for years plankton has done everything
in his power to uncover the truth but
sadly he's never gotten close to
discovering what Mr Krabs's secret
ingredient is
so here's the theory that makes more
than a little sense the secret
ingredient doesn't exist instead mr.
Krabs uses this clever marketing trick
to get customers to choose his
establishment over the Chum Bucket the
mind works in a curious way so if
someone tells you that your burger has a
secret ingredient in it you might be
inclined to think that it tastes better
than a regular burger the placebo effect
is a strong one and marketing tactics
never fail to amaze us in season 6
episode 122 Karen gives plankton some
advice that he immediately takes to
heart instead of trying to copy the
famous krabby patty Clinton starts to
use advertisement to his advantage and
to his big surprise customers start
pouring into the Chum Bucket and
ordering burgers so could it be that
Krusty Krab secret ingredient is nothing
more than a clever gimmick plankton the
Chum Bucket in the Krusty Krab art
fast-food restaurants that had their
grand opening on the very same day
however the Krusty Krab is way more
successful than the chumbucket will ever
be and the reason behind this is that
the chumbucket doesn't serve Krabby
Patties in season 3 were introduced to
an episode titled Plankton's army which
brought forth an interesting concept in
this episode plankton finally gets his
hands on Mr Krabs's secret recipe only
to find out that with a krabby patty is
made with freshly ground plankton this
information causes plankton and his
relatives to run for the hills
however Mr Krabs later reveals that
plankton is not the secret ingredient
but simply a ruse to get plankton off
his back mr. Krabs is no fool which is
why we wouldn't put it past him to trick
plankton into thinking that the actual
secret ingredient was nothing more than
a joke so it's very possible that
plankton is indeed the secret ingredient
and that mr. Krabs pulled a fast one
over everyone's eyes if there's one
thing that's for sure is that plankton
is never going to test out this theory
because well that would just be wrong
seaweed and tofu no one wants to admit
that the Bikini Bottom residents are
borderline cannibals but we have to face
the fact at the end of the day the
krabby patty is made with some form of
meat whether it's crab or fish however
in a perfect world none of these
ingredients would be found in the Krusty
Krabs kitchen some fast-food restaurants
use meat fillers to make the most profit
so knowing this why would the Krusty
Krab be any different many restaurants
have found ways to make tofu taste like
the real deal
and since Bikini Bottom has it's very
own scientist and inventor we're led to
believe that Sandy Cheeks might be
helping mr. Krabs create the ultimate
fish friendly patty tofu was created
when a Chinese chef combined seaweed and
soy together causing it to curdle and
since seaweed is an easy thing for mr.
Krabs to acquire this ingredient might
just make up the krabby patty we all
know and love if this is true it makes
perfect sense that mr. Krabs would
protect his krabby patty recipe with his
life after all who knows how many
customers he would lose if they found
out that they were paying full price for
a vegetarian burger if you think this is
bad wait until you hear the following
theories number one on this list might
just
make your jaw drop all the way to bikini
village fish burgers although many of us
wouldn't expect fish to eat other fish
this is a very normal occurrence so by
default it's very possible that Krabby
Patties are made with fish and a few
other key ingredients when it comes to
making money mr. Krabs is ruthless
which is why SpongeBob and Patrick have
often had to save secret errs from their
boss in the episode jellyfish hunter mr.
Krabs starts capturing jellyfish and
using them as a topping the jelly proves
to be a highly addictive add-on and a
profitable one at that despite having to
capture and suck jellyfish dry mr. Krabs
doesn't seem at all bothered by his
actions this makes us wonder just how
far the fast-food owner will go to make
some extra cash
if imprisoning jellyfish against their
will and torturing them isn't a deal
breaker we'd hate to see what Mr Krabs
does to the fish he captures it's
possible that mr. Krabs throws
everything he catches into a blender to
create that famous krabby patty
after all doing so is cost-effective
[Music]
whale burgers most of us have never paid
much thought to the fact that mr. Krabs
daughter is a sperm whale
and although the crab swears that pearl
is his biological daughter
we highly doubt that this is true after
all pearl is the furthest thing away
from a crab when a whale passes away
their body floats to the bottom of the
ocean where it's later polished off by
fish sharks lobsters shrimps and crabs
in fact the scent of a whale carcass is
so strong that it attracts sea dwellers
from miles away so want to hear a theory
that'll change the way you look at mr.
Krabs for good well here it goes some
believe that mr. Krabs stumbled across a
sperm whale carcass only to find a baby
whale swimming around it he then chose
to adopt the little whale and build his
restaurant on top of the carcass for the
next twenty something years mr. Krabs
has used sperm meat to lure customers to
his cash register and his plan has
worked flawlessly although it's
perfectly normal for sea critters to eat
whale mr. Krabs keeps his Krabby Patty
ingredients top-secret because should
they ever get out pearl would find out
that her
if father has been getting rich off of
her mother's back now if that isn't
creepy we don't know what is Poseidon
power mr. Krabs knows that the secret to
his success is making his customers come
back for more so knowing this he chose
to add a special ingredient that would
keep him rich for the rest of his life
it's no secret that bikini bottom
dwellers are obsessed with Krabby
Patties so much so that the entire
village nearly went crazy when mr. Krabs
his secret ingredient was stolen in the
Spongebob movie sponge out of water it's
been revealed that the krabby patty is
made with a pinch of king Neptune's
Poseidon powder which is known to be an
extremely addictive substance in fact if
this substance was being used on dry
land users would most likely be sent to
jail mr. Krabs only cares about money
which is why sprinkling his food with
illegal additives doesn't seem to faze
him whatsoever however when his secret
ingredient was stolen he came clean
about what would happen to Bikini Bottom
if tabby patties went extinct for good
and believe us when we say that it's not
pretty so there you have it guys some of
the most insane krabby patty theories on
the market before you go let us know
which one makes the most sense to you in
the comments below and that's a wrap
make sure to subscribe to the things for
more awesome videos to come your way
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]